I was surprised this week during this interview I was doing, I sat down to talk to the guy, Jim McManus is his name, whose book, Positively Fifth Street, is the book that actually started me playing poker years ago. And we were going to do this interview about great poker hands. And you know that saying, know when to hold them, know when to fold them? This interview was going to be about moments when players showed an almost supernatural ability, an uncanny power to know whether they should get out of a hand before they're crushed.
本周我在做采访时感到很惊讶，我和那个叫吉姆·麦克马纳斯（Jim McManus）的人坐下来交谈，多年前正是他的那本《Positively Fifth Street》让我开始打扑克。我们原定要进行一次关于伟大扑克牌局的采访。你知道那句名言吗，“要知道何时跟注，要知道何时弃牌”？这次采访本来是关于玩家展现出近乎超自然的能力、那种敏锐的直觉，让他们在遭受重创前知道该何时退出牌局。
I'll tell you what I have. I have four examples.
我来告诉你我有什么。我有四个例子。
One of his books is actually a history of poker called Cowboys Full-- he knows all kinds of poker lore. And so Jim shows up with four examples, and three of them were poker hands.
他的一本书其实是关于扑克的历史，书名叫《牛仔全满》（Cowboys Full）——他通晓各种扑克知识。所以吉姆带来了四个例子，其中三个是扑克牌局。
And then I have the Cuban Missile Crisis between Khrushchev and Kennedy, in which Khrushchev folded, thus saving the world from a nuclear exchange.
还有一个是赫鲁晓夫和肯尼迪之间的古巴导弹危机，赫鲁晓夫弃牌了，从而使世界免于核战争。
Well, I think let's start with that one. So how does that lay out as a poker hand? Just walk me through it.
好吧，我想我们就从那个开始吧。那么作为一场扑克牌局，这该怎么解释呢？给我讲讲。
Well, Khrushchev and the Soviets had bet that the young, inexperienced Kennedy, who they had met in Europe and had read him as not quite as tough as the previous president, Eisenhower. They decided that they would try to put missile bases on Cuba. And Kennedy startled them by raising, by blockading the island, insisting that the bases be taken apart, and putting our nuclear forces on highest alert. And Khrushchev made what is called an awesome lay down. He agreed to take the sites, to take them apart. There could have easily been a nuclear war over that.
嗯，赫鲁晓夫和苏联人赌定年轻、缺乏经验的肯尼迪——他们在欧洲见过他，认为他不如前任总统艾森豪威尔强硬。他们决定尝试在古巴建立导弹基地。肯尼迪通过封锁该岛、坚持拆除基地并将我们的核力量置于最高警戒状态，以加注的方式令他们大吃一惊。赫鲁晓夫做出了所谓的“惊人弃牌”。他同意将这些基地拆除。在那场危机中，本可能轻易爆发核战争。
So in this reading of it, Khrushchev's original bet was really a bluff?
所以按照这种解读，赫鲁晓夫最初的下注其实是在虚张声势（bluff）？
It was a testing bet. Kennedy needed to figure out whether he was bluffing or he actually was ready to commit all the way. So he raised by blockading the island, communicating to them-- bluffing-- that we were ready to make a nuclear strike. Whether or not we were bluffing still remains unknown. And Khrushchev's response was to fold.
那是一次试探性的下注。肯尼迪需要弄清楚他是在虚张声势，还是真的准备孤注一掷。所以肯尼迪通过封锁该岛来加注，传达了一个信号——虚张声势——即我们准备进行核打击。我们是否在虚张声势至今仍不得而知。而赫鲁晓夫的应对是弃牌。
Of course, this is a perfect week to talk about politics as poker. All this week, Barack Obama's been in a high stakes game of chicken with Congressional Republicans over shutting down the government, each side firing what I guess Jim would call testing bets, insisting on their version of the federal budget, demanding the other side would fold. Each side calling the other's bluff day, after day, after day. Neither side willing to toss in their cards.
当然，本周是讨论将政治比作扑克的绝佳时机。整个星期，巴拉克·奥巴马与国会共和党人就在政府关门问题上进行着一场高风险的“胆小鬼博弈”，双方都在发射吉姆所称的“试探性下注”，坚持各自版本的联邦预算，要求对方弃牌。双方都在日复一日地拆穿对方的虚张声势。谁也不愿意先扔出底牌。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, to help our nation's leaders, and the rest of us as well, Know When To Fold 'Em. Stories about people who have to figure out when they should give up. When is it time for a tactical retreat? We have dictators, drunks, an ungrateful kid facing off with his parent, and a team of guys chasing a lone man through the Brazilian rain forest. None of them on today's show wants to fold their cards. And as Jim McManus points out, figuring out when to hold them and when to fold them isn't always so obvious, at least when it comes to real games of poker.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。在今天的节目中，为了帮助我们的国家领导人，也帮助我们其他人，我们来讨论“何时该弃牌”。这些故事讲述了人们必须弄清楚何时该放弃。什么时候是战略撤退的时机？我们有独裁者、醉鬼、与父母对峙的不肖子，还有一队人在巴西雨林中追捕一名独行者。他们中没有人在今天的节目里想弃牌。正如吉姆·麦克马纳斯所指出的，弄清楚何时持牌、何时弃牌并不总是那么显而易见，尤其是在真正的扑克游戏中。
Well, the major hand of my life-- an example of one in which a player either foolishly or brilliantly decides to hold them rather than fold them-- was a pot that the other guy in the hand was TJ Cloutier, who was also the winningest tournament poker player in history.
好吧，我人生中最重要的牌局——一个玩家或是愚蠢、或是英明地决定持牌而非弃牌的例子——是一个底池，牌局中的另一位对手是TJ·克鲁蒂埃（TJ Cloutier），他也是历史上赢得奖金最多的锦标赛扑克选手。
Jim calls it the major hand in his life because it's the hand that made the most serious players in the world take notice of him. This was back in 2000. Jim was covering the World Series of Poker for Harper's Magazine, and he entered the tournament, his first one ever. And he was terrified. He actually ended up at the final table, walking away with a quarter million dollars, which would have been impossible without this hand against one of his poker heroes, TJ Cloutier.
吉姆称之为他人生中最重要的牌局，因为这手牌让世界上最严肃的牌手开始注意到他。那是2000年。吉姆当时正为《哈珀杂志》（Harper's Magazine）报道世界扑克系列赛，他参加了比赛，这是他第一次参赛。他当时吓坏了。他最终进入了决赛桌，拿走了25万美元奖金，如果不是这手对阵他偶像之一TJ·克鲁蒂埃的牌，这本是不可能的。
I had studied and even memorized long passages of his book about how to play hold 'em. And the hold cards he focused most of his attention on were ace, king.
我研究过，甚至背诵过他关于如何玩德州扑克那本书里的长篇段落。他最关注的底牌是A-K。
So, in this crucial life changing moment, Jim's across the table from TJ, and that is the hand that Jim gets-- ace, king. Jim bets, just like it says to do in the book. Everybody folds but TJ, who raises.
所以，在这个改变命运的关键时刻，吉姆坐在TJ对面，而吉姆拿到的正是这手牌——A-K。吉姆下注了，就像书中说的那样。除了TJ，其他人都弃牌了，而TJ加注了。
You have to also bear in mind that he is a large former tight end in the Canadian Football League. So it's not just the size, the number of chips he's pushing forward, it's the growl and the snarl factor, and the physical intimidation that sort of go along with it.
你还必须记住，他曾是加拿大橄榄球联盟的一名大型边锋。所以这不仅是体型、他推入筹码的数量，还有那种咆哮声和野兽般的特质，以及随之而来的身体威慑感。
Jim says that he knew the relevant passage from TJ's book so well that he could nearly recite it. And he knew that he should either raise or he should fold. And then he does neither. He matches TJ's bet-- he calls-- thinking that TJ is probably bluffing, but too scared to raise him. Next time TJ bets, Jim calls again. And the next time after that, which puts Jim all in. All his chips are now in the pot. And in the end, when all the cards come down, neither he nor TJ even has a pair.
吉姆说他太熟悉TJ书中相关的段落了，几乎能背出来。他知道自己要么该加注，要么该弃牌。但他两者都没做。他跟注了TJ的下注——他跟了——心想TJ可能在虚张声势，但又不敢加注他。下次TJ下注时，吉姆再次跟注。再下一次也是，这使得吉姆全押了。他所有的筹码现在都在底池里。最终，当所有的牌翻开时，他和TJ甚至连一对都没有。
And when we turned over our cards, he had ace, nine, I had ace, king, and I won a pot that made me the chip leader in the tournament. But now, with 11 years of experience playing tournament poker, that's a call that I would never make. I would never call all in with no pair in a big tournament.
当我们翻开底牌时，他有A-9，我有A-K，我赢下了一个让我成为锦标赛筹码领先者的底池。但现在，有了11年的锦标赛扑克经验，那样的跟注我绝不会再做。我永远不会在大型锦标赛中不带对子就全押跟注。
So at that time, you're saying, in the end it worked out to be the right move, but you're saying it was a mistake?
所以当时你说，结果证明这是正确的举动，但你认为那是一个错误？
It was probably a mistake.
这可能确实是个错误。
A mistake, because given the aggressiveness of TJ's bets, TJ very well could have had at least a little pair. even a pair of twos would have beaten Jim. But Jim was such an amateur at that point, he didn't fold the way an experienced player would.
是个错误，因为考虑到TJ下注的侵略性，TJ很有可能至少有一对。哪怕是一对2都能赢吉姆。但吉姆当时是个菜鸟，他没有像经验丰富的玩家那样弃牌。
It's interesting, because I've heard that professional players, they say in some situations the hardest person to play against is an amateur, because they can't predict what the amateur is going to do when they put pro moves on them. And in a way, what you're saying is that's what happened right here.
这很有趣，因为我听说职业牌手说，在某些情况下，最难对付的就是业余选手，因为当他们对业余选手使出职业招数时，他们无法预判业余选手会做什么。从某种意义上说，你所说的正是这里发生的情况。
That's exactly what happened. And my call was in one sense a brilliant call. Amarillo Slim, who was the color commentator at the time, said, "That boy's got the heart of a cliff diver. I'm going to bet on him to win." And yet, other people, including TJ, said, "He played it more like a deer in the headlights. He was too scared to fold." My ability to suss out the situation was inadequate to realize that I was probably beaten-- even though I wasn't, I was probably beaten. And that I made a mistake that just turned out to--
正是如此。从某种意义上讲，我的跟注是一次精彩的跟注。当时担任评论员的阿马里洛·斯利姆（Amarillo Slim）说：“那小子有悬崖跳水运动员的心脏。我要赌他赢。”然而，其他人，包括TJ都说：“他打得更像是一只被车灯惊住的鹿。他太害怕而不敢弃牌了。”我对局势的洞察能力不足以让我意识到我可能已经输了——尽管我没输，但我可能已经输了。我犯了一个错误，只是最终——
Make you a hero.
让你成了英雄。
Yeah, make me a hero. Sometimes the line between a foolish call and a brilliant one, it just depends on how the cards-- the rest of the hand gets dealt out.
是的，让我成了英雄。有时愚蠢的跟注和精彩的跟注之间的界限，只取决于剩下的牌如何分发。
And the fact that so much of the time you really are just kind of in the dark, and you have to figure out, "Should I raise, should I fold these?" Is that the thing you hate about poker, is that the thing you love about poker?
事实上，很多时候你真的处于盲目状态，你必须弄清楚“我该加注，还是该弃牌？”，这是你讨厌扑克的原因，还是你热爱扑克的原因？
No, that's the thing that I love about poker. That's what makes it an art from. The thing that I hate about poker is that you can sit there, and puzzle it out, and think it through, and come up with exactly the right answer, and play the hand perfectly, and your opponent can play the hand as stupidly as he can and still get saved by the dealer on the river, and you lose. The fact that you can play the hand well and lose all of your money is really uncool.
不，那是我热爱扑克的原因。那正是让它成为一门艺术的原因。我讨厌扑克的一点是，你可以坐在那里，绞尽脑汁，思考透彻，想出完全正确的答案，把手牌打得完美无缺，而你的对手可以把手牌打得尽可能愚蠢，却依然能在河牌被荷官拯救，而你输了。你可以打得很好却输掉所有钱的事实，真的很糟糕。
That's a rub. It's hard to know when to fold them and when to hold them, much less when to walk away and when to run. And even when you figure it out, even when you suss out exactly the right thing to do, the cards can come down in some crazy way that favors your opponent and you lose anyway. We have four stories of people navigating all of that away from the poker table. Stay with us.
这就是难点。很难知道何时该弃牌，何时该持牌，更不用说何时离开，何时奔跑。即使你弄清楚了，即使你洞察出了完全正确的做法，牌也可能以某种疯狂的方式落下，从而偏袒你的对手，而你还是输了。我们有四个故事讲述了人们在扑克桌外是如何处理这一切的。请留步。
Act One, Is This War or Is This Hearts? Dave Dickerson has this story of laying down his cards, which includes one of the most exemplary pieces of parenting I think I have ever heard of.
第一幕，这是战争还是红心大战？戴夫·迪克森（Dave Dickerson）讲述了这个关于他放下底牌的故事，其中包括我认为我听过的最模范的育儿行为之一。
When I was 28 years old, I came back home for the first time in six years fully aware that I was the black sheep. I had rejected my faith. I had rejected Tucson, Arizona. I was the only one in the family who wasn't married. I was the only one who couldn't even speak Spanish.
当我28岁时，我第一次在六年内回到家，完全意识到自己是个异类。我拒绝了我的信仰。我拒绝了亚利桑那州的图森。我是家里唯一没结婚的人。我是唯一连西班牙语都不会说的人。
And I was just sitting with my dad in a booth at a diner, and it should have been just this kind of innocent thing, where I'm visiting after six years, and it's nice to catch up. But it wasn't like that. We were facing each other. We both had, as it happens, cowboy hats and cowboy boots. And I remember thinking, this is a showdown. Because my dad and I were at war. My dad didn't know this, but I was at war with him. I was at war with all Christians, and I was just waiting for an excuse to fire a shot.
我当时和爸爸坐在餐馆的一个卡座里，本来应该是一件很无辜的事情，我离家六年回来探望，叙叙旧挺好的。但事实并非如此。我们面对面坐着。碰巧我们都戴着牛仔帽，穿着牛仔靴。我记得我当时在想，这是一场对决。因为我和爸爸处于战争状态。我爸爸不知道这一点，但我确实在和他进行战争。我和所有的基督徒处于战争状态，我只是在等待一个借口去开火。
I'd been raised an evangelical Christian-- you know, conservative, Bible-believing Christian-- and I loved it so much that I said, I'm going to be a pastor. I'm going to learn everything I can learn. And I went off and I majored in religious studies in college. And from my very first scholarly class in the history of the Bible, my faith began to crumble until there was nothing left. And I now had this game I could play, where if you open a Bible to any page, I could find five flaws in it.
我是在福音派基督徒环境中长大的——你知道，保守的、相信圣经的基督徒——我非常热爱它，以至于我说，我要成为一名牧师。我要学习我能学到的一切。我去了大学，主修宗教研究。从我在圣经历史学的第一节学术课开始，我的信仰就开始崩溃，直到一无所有。我现在有了一个游戏可以玩：如果你随手翻开圣经的任何一页，我就能找出五个缺陷。
So I'd spent this entire time, not just with my dad, but certainly this particular evening, just waiting for a chance. Just mention the virgin birth, just once, and I'll tell you it's a mistranslation from Isaiah. Just mention Second Peter and I can prove to you it's a second century forgery. Say anything at all, please, please, about the Antichrist, revelation, the end times, anything like that, and I have a screed set up that's so blistering it would make Billy Graham feel ridiculous. And I had all this ammunition, and I couldn't wait to use it. I was just looking for an excuse. It had sort of turned me into a jackass.
所以我在那段时间里，不仅是和我爸爸在一起，尤其是那个特别的晚上，只是在等待一个机会。只要提到童贞女受孕，就一次，我就会告诉你那是对以赛亚书的误译。只要提到《彼得后书》，我就能向你证明那是二世纪的伪作。随便说点什么，拜托，关于反基督、启示录、末日，任何类似的话题，我准备好了一篇极其尖刻的文章，足以让比利·格雷厄姆（Billy Graham）感到可笑。我拥有所有的弹药，迫不及待地想使用它。我只是在寻找一个借口。这让我变得像个蠢货。
Now, what my dad didn't know was that one of the reasons I was so excited is I actually was just coming off a victory. The previous night, I had argued my brother-in-law to a standstill. He had mentioned something about how proud he was about being a Christian, because everything in the Bible was so scientifically accurate. And I went a little nuts and I said, "Oh yeah, what about this thing?" And there's this tiny little section, just one sentence in like, Exodus, where the Israelites are fighting the Amorites or somebody, and God does a miracle where he makes the sun stand still for an entire day, in order to give the Israelites a chance to recover and give them more time to fight.
我爸爸不知道的是，我之所以这么兴奋，其中一个原因是我刚打完胜仗。前一天晚上，我和姐夫辩论到了僵持不下。他提到他是多么为自己是一名基督徒而自豪，因为圣经里的一切在科学上都是那么准确。我有点发疯，我说：“哦是吗，那这个呢？”在《出埃及记》里有一小段，就一句话，以色列人在和亚摩利人或其他什么人打仗，上帝施展了奇迹，让太阳静止了一整天，为了给以色列人喘息的机会，给他们更多时间战斗。
And I told my brother-in-law, "You really believe this? You believe this actually happened? That God stopped the entire planet from rotating, stopped gravity, all of things that would have to happen for the sun to stand still? Is that the most sensible thing the most powerful being in the world can do?" And my brother-in-law said, "Well, OK, that's weird, and I wish it weren't in there, but if I doubt that, where do I stop?"
我告诉姐夫：“你真的相信这个？你相信这真的发生了？上帝让整个星球停止自转，停止重力，所有为了让太阳静止必须发生的事情？这是世界上最有权能的存在能做的最明智的事情吗？”我姐夫说：“好吧，那很奇怪，我希望它不在里面，但如果我怀疑这个，我在哪里停下呢？”
And that, I knew, was as close as I was going to get to him saying, "You're right and I'm wrong." I remember looking at the clock, and it was 5:00 in the morning. I had argued this one point for seven hours. And I realized, this is like my job. I just put in a full working day. Obviously, I was obsessed.
我知道，那是我能让他说出“你是对的，我错了”最接近的时刻。我记得看着时钟，已经是凌晨5点了。我在这一点上争论了七个小时。我意识到，这就像我的工作。我刚完成了一个完整的工作日。显然，我着迷了。
At the time I was 28 years old. I was also a virgin, and I'd been a virgin because the Bible says so, because I thought Jesus wanted it that way. And then Jesus vanished on me. I had spent all of my life trying to be good, trying to do the right thing, and, you know, trusting that this would be rewarded. And then my faith collapsed.
当时我28岁。我还是个处男，我保持童贞是因为圣经上这么说，因为我以为耶稣希望那样。然后耶稣从我生活中消失了。我一生都在努力变得善良，试图做正确的事，并且，你知道，相信这会得到回报。然后我的信仰崩溃了。
And there's no betrayal like losing 10 years of your life, your sexual peak basically. I'm never going to get that back. And I was furious. And I didn't know who to blame. But I knew I could help other people from having the same horrible experience. And I was looking at my brother-in-law and thinking-- you know, we were arguing about Genesis, but in my mind I was thinking, there is no way you have a good sex life. You know, because the Bible doesn't care, and pleasure doesn't even matter in the Bible. But I can save you.
没有什么比浪费了10年生命，基本上是你性欲最旺盛的时期更令人背叛的了。我再也回不去了。我非常愤怒。我不知道该责怪谁。但我知道我可以帮助别人不再经历同样的恐怖体验。我看着姐夫，心想——你知道，我们当时在争论《创世纪》，但在我脑海里我想的是，你不可能有美满的性生活。因为圣经不在乎这些，快乐在圣经里根本不重要。但我能拯救你。
And with this kind of exciting, thrilling victory still humming in the back of my head, I was sitting there with my dad in the diner. Because a brother-in-law is one thing. A dad is someone else. I needed to save him. And so I said, "So, dad, what's your life like right now?" And he said, "Well, I found a new church home." And I heard church, and I perked up, and I was ready to go. But I thought, eh, church, not much to argue about there, people go to church, OK, it's nothing biblical.
怀着这种令人兴奋、惊心动魄的胜利感，我坐在餐馆里和我爸爸在一起。因为姐夫是一回事。爸爸是另一个人。我需要拯救他。于是我说：“爸爸，你现在的生活怎么样？”他说：“嗯，我找到了一个新的教会之家。”听到“教会”，我振作起来，准备开战。但我想，呃，教会，没什么好争论的，人们去教堂，好啊，那又不涉及圣经。
And he said, "You know, it's a small church, and the pastor found out that I play the accordion, and he made me the music minister. That'll be nice." And again, I was like, [? tightened, ?] but I thought, "Meh, music ministry, no, nothing there." And then he said, "You know, this other kind of interesting thing is happening, I've been praying about it, and I think I'm going to be a missionary." And that struck a chord. I sat upright, and I went, "Oh really? A missionary? Where are you going to go?" And then he said, "Oh, Spain."
他说：“你知道，这是一个小教会，牧师发现我会拉手风琴，就让我当音乐牧师。那会很不错。”我再次觉得，[？绷紧了？]，但我心想：“啧，音乐事工，不，那也没什么。”然后他说：“你知道，还有另一件挺有趣的事情正在发生，我一直在为它祈祷，我想我要成为一名传教士。”这触动了我的心弦。我坐直了，我说：“哦真的？传教士？你要去哪里？”然后他说：“哦，西班牙。”
And I snapped. I said, "Oh, of course. Of course you're going to go to Spain. That is so arrogant. Only an evangelical Christian would say, oh, those poor benighted Spaniards need to learn about Jesus. You know," I said, "evangelical Christianity as a way, the whole model of salvation that you guys preach, wasn't even around till the 19th century. You claim to represent all of Christianity, and you're really just the tiny sliver at the end of the iceberg. And you know, the model of salvation you're even selling is so weird. Conversion should be the response of the whole person to a call from God on a deep personal level, and evangelical Christians have turned it into this transaction, like a merchandise, like a, try our God and your life will be better. Say this prayer, and now here's the merchandising table. It's just horrible."
我崩溃了。我说：“哦，当然。你当然要去西班牙。那太傲慢了。只有福音派基督徒才会说，哦，那些可怜的、无知的西班牙人需要了解耶稣。你知道，”我说，“福音派基督教作为一种方式，你们宣讲的整个救赎模式，甚至直到19世纪才出现。你们声称代表整个基督教，而实际上你们只是冰山末端的一小片碎片。你知道，你推销的救赎模式甚至都很奇怪。悔改应该是整个人对上帝召唤的深层个人层面的回应，而福音派基督徒把它变成了一种交易，就像商品，就像‘尝试我们的上帝，你的生活会变得更好’。念这句祷告，然后这就是商品陈列台。这太可怕了。”
"And Dad," I said, "You're saving people? What are you saving them from? Hell, may I guess? Because let me point something else out to you. Hell is a mistranslation from the King James of four completely different words for the afterlife. Gehenna, and hades, and sheol, and King James just kind of rounded them all up to hell. And the idea of eternal torture has no precedent in the Old Testament. It has never made any moral sense. And the second you believe in hell, you're undermining everything good. Because a morality based in fear can only bring out the worst in people, and never their best."
“爸爸，”我说，“你在拯救人们？你在从什么拯救他们？地狱，我可以猜猜吗？因为让我为你指出另一点。地狱是钦定版圣经中对四个完全不同的来世词汇的误译。欣嫩谷（Gehenna）、冥府（Hades）、阴间（Sheol），钦定版圣经只是把它们都归纳为地狱。永恒折磨的想法在旧约中没有先例。它在道德上从未有任何意义。你相信地狱的那一秒，你就在破坏所有美好的事物。因为建立在恐惧基础上的道德只能激发出人们最坏的一面，而不是最好的一面。”
And I just rambled on like this. And I knew, essentially, while I was doing this, I was also assaulting his dream. You know, saying everything he was excited about, that he was sharing with me, was misbegotten, was a bad idea, was morally corrupt. But all he had to do was admit I was right and then we'd be OK. And I really didn't know what was going to happen now, because I'd just fired the first shot.
我就这样滔滔不绝。我知道，当我在做这件事时，我实际上也在攻击他的梦想。你知道，说他所兴奋的一切，他与我分享的一切，都是错误的，是个坏主意，在道德上是腐败的。但他所要做的只是承认我是对的，那我们就没事了。我真的不知道现在会发生什么，因为我刚开了第一枪。
And he just quietly let me do my thing. And when I'd settled down and gotten my piece out, he said, "David, I'm really proud of everything you've done. And I'm really glad that you enjoy studying all these things, and thinking all these thoughts. But I've got to tell you, before I became a Christian, I was miserable. I wanted to kill myself. I wanted to get a divorce from your mom."
他只是静静地让我把话说完。当我也冷静下来，表达完我的观点后，他说：“大卫，我为你所做的一切感到非常骄傲。我很高兴你喜欢学习所有这些东西，思考所有这些想法。但我必须告诉你，在我成为基督徒之前，我非常痛苦。我想自杀。我想和你妈妈离婚。”
And I remembered, suddenly, like I was six years old and I was back in the car, and I remember driving in the station wagon with my dad from South Dakota to Tucson, because dad had had a miserable life, had a nervous breakdown, he was rebuilding everything. And he was holding a cigarette out the window the whole ride down. I remember-- as a child, this had had a strong impression on me-- about halfway through the trip, he simply threw away all of his cigarettes. Never picked them up again. That was his conversion. That was the start of the change in his life.
我突然记起来，就像我6岁时，我回到车里，我记得我爸爸开车带着我从南达科他州去图森的旅行车，因为爸爸曾过着悲惨的生活，精神崩溃，他在重建一切。整个路途中他一直把烟叼在窗外。我记得——作为一个孩子，这给我留下了深刻的印象——旅程进行到一半时，他简单地扔掉了所有的香烟。再也没有捡起来。那就是他的皈依。那是他人生转变的开始。
And my dad continued. He said, "You know, when I first went to Grace Chapel," which was the church where he had converted. He said, "I thought those people were crazy." And when I was eight years old, I had gone to Grace Chapel with him. And this was a charismatic church. The kind where people raise their hands, and they speak in tongues, and they anoint people with oil, and they pray for miraculous healings, and people roll on the ground sometimes, or dance.
我爸爸继续说。他说：“你知道，当我第一次去格蕾丝礼拜堂（Grace Chapel）时，”那是他皈依的教会。他说：“我以为那些人疯了。”当我8岁时，我曾和他一起去过格蕾丝礼拜堂。那是灵恩派教会。人们会举起手，说方言，用油膏抹人，为神奇的治愈祈祷，人们有时会在地上打滚或跳舞。
And my dad said, "You know, I was just staring at the stuff these people were doing, and I thought, this is crazy. But I could not ignore the love in that room, and the care they had for each other. And I kept going back, and I kept going back. And I wanted it to make sense to me, and I wanted it. And finally one night, I prayed. And I said, God, if I have to cut my own head off to be happy, I will do it. So I know you've gone to college, and you've learned all these things, but here's what I know, David. I followed Jesus and the lord gave me a family."
我爸爸说：“你知道，我只是盯着这些人做的事情，我想，这太疯狂了。但我无法忽视房间里的爱，以及他们彼此之间的关心。我不断回去，不断回去。我希望它对我来说有意义，我渴望它。终于有一天晚上，我祈祷了。我说，上帝，如果为了快乐我必须割掉自己的头，我会做的。所以我知道你上了大学，学了所有这些东西，但这是我知道的，大卫。我跟随耶稣，上帝给了我一个家。”
My parents really had almost gotten divorced. I remember one time I ran across a notebook where my dad and my mom had divided everything up on a piece of paper. You know, who was going to get the TV and that kind of thing. They'd gotten. that close. And then my dad converted, and he said, "No, we're sticking this out. I'm going to make this work." And it had.
我父母确实差点离婚。我记得有一次我翻到一个笔记本，上面我爸爸和妈妈把所有东西都分好了。你知道，谁要电视机之类的东西。他们已经走到了那一步。然后我爸爸皈依了，他说：“不，我们要坚持下去。我要让它成功。”结果确实成功了。
And my brother, too. He's deeply conservative, listens to all the right wing talk radio and so forth. And he's got to be convinced that I'm going to hell. But this one time, I was on this trip, and I was a student, and he gave me $300. And he said, "Don't bother repaying it."
我哥哥也是。他非常保守，听所有的右翼脱口秀等等。他肯定确信我要下地狱。但有一次，我在旅行，我还是个学生，他给了我300美元。他说：“别费心还了。”
And I remember looking at my dad, and I thought-- had sort of expected to argue like I had with my brother-in-law. Not to win, but to come to some kind of armistice, some kind of truce where we're like, "Well, we'll agree to disagree, but I see your point. It's a good point." I hadn't expected to lose completely. Because you can't argue with decency. You can't argue with goodness.
我记得看着爸爸，我想——我本来预想会像和姐夫那样争论。不是为了赢，而是为了达成某种停战，某种休战，比如“好吧，我们同意保留各自的意见，但我看到了你的观点。这是一个好观点。”我没想到会彻底输掉。因为你无法与体面争论。你无法与善良争论。
The thing about the Bible is, it's huge. I could poke at it because I could pick at anything I wanted-- you know, talking snakes, virgin birth. But eventually, I came around to thinking, well, maybe religion doesn't have to be consistent. Maybe you can just like it enough for it to be good. Maybe religion can be something more like-- like, I'm a big Star Trek fan. And if you asked me, I would say, I love Star Trek. But if you asked me to defend individual episodes, I would be at a loss, because I can't go to bat for everything Star Trek did. I just love the concept.
关于圣经的事情是，它太庞大了。我之所以能攻击它，是因为我可以随意挑剔任何东西——你知道，会说话的蛇，童贞女受孕。但最终，我开始想，也许宗教不需要一致。也许你仅仅喜欢它到足够让它变得美好就可以了。也许宗教可以更像——就像，我是个超级《星际迷航》迷。如果问我，我会说，我爱《星际迷航》。但如果你让我为每一集辩护，我会无言以对，因为我无法为《星际迷航》所做的一切背书。我只是喜欢这个概念。
And maybe religion could be like that. So what I said to my dad was, "Oh, look, here comes the waitress." And we got our Sprite, and had our hamburgers, and we looked at each other, raised the glass, had a bite. And my dad didn't know this, but we were having communion.
也许宗教可以像那样。所以我对爸爸说：“哦，看，服务员来了。”我们要了雪碧，吃了汉堡，我们看着对方，举杯，咬了一口。我爸爸不知道，但我们当时在进行圣餐礼。
Dave Dickerson. He's the author of a book of short stories like this one called House of Cards.
戴夫·迪克森。他是像这样短篇故事集《纸牌屋》（House of Cards）的作者。
[MUSIC - "CHRISTIANS AND PAGANS" BY DAR WILLIAMS]
[音乐 - 达·威廉姆斯（Dar Williams）的《基督徒与异教徒》（CHRISTIANS AND PAGANS）]
Act Two, Kings Do Not Fold. What's a dictator? Yes, an absolute ruler, yes, a tyrant, yes to all that. But a dictator is also, in the vast majority of cases, someone who is absolutely, fundamentally not leaving. 30 years in office, 40 years in office, these are not people who know when it is time to step aside. Witness the last few months of news from the Mideast, which Nancy Updike has some thoughts about.
第二幕，国王从不弃牌。什么是独裁者？是的，绝对统治者，是的，暴君，这些都对。但在绝大多数情况下，独裁者也是绝对、根本不会离开的人。在位30年，在位40年，这些人不知道什么时候该下台。看看中东最近几个月的新闻，南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）对此有一些想法。
Looking at one dictator at a time, it's easy to get caught up in what's unique about him. For instance, some specific brutality his regime favors-- Kim Jong-il's forced labor camps. Or you can get distracted by his eccentricities-- Muammar Qaddafi's very special, no light reflecting black hair dye, Saddam Hussein's side career as a novelist.
观察一个独裁者，很容易陷入他独特的地方。例如，他的政权所偏爱的某种具体暴行——金正日的强制劳动营。或者你会被他的古怪行为分散注意力——穆阿迈尔·卡扎菲那种非常特别的、不反光的黑发染发剂，萨达姆·侯赛因作为小说家的副业。
But I've been pretty glued to the coverage of all these Middle East dictators who've been under siege for the last few months. And the other day, after listening to yet another speech by one of them, I drew up a rough checklist. I want to read it here. I've been calling it, "the 11 Stages of Mideast Dictator Damage Control." It's a working title.
但我一直紧盯着这些过去几个月处于围困中的中东独裁者的报道。前几天，在听了其中一位的又一次演讲后，我草拟了一份清单。我想在这里读一下。我把它称为“中东独裁者危机处理的11个阶段”。这是一个暂定名。
And not every dictator does them exactly the same way, or does them in exactly the same order. But in general, it goes like this.
并非每个独裁者的做法都完全相同，或者顺序完全一致。但总的来说，它是这样的。
Stage one, shut down the internet. Stage two, send thugs. On foot, or on horseback if you're in Egypt. Stage three, attack and arrest journalists. Stage four, shoot people. Stage five, promise to investigate who shot people. Stage six, do a meaningless political reshuffle. Stage seven, blame Al Jazeera. Stage eight, organize paid demonstrations in favor of your regime. Stage nine, make a condescending speech about how much you love the youth. Stage 10, threaten that the country will fall into chaos without you. Stage 11, blame foreign agitators. There is actually a stage 12, but it's the one the dictators never want to get to, because it is leave. Get out.
第一阶段，关闭互联网。第二阶段，派遣暴徒。徒步，或者如果你在埃及，就骑马。第三阶段，攻击和逮捕记者。第四阶段，枪杀民众。第五阶段，承诺调查是谁枪杀了民众。第六阶段，进行毫无意义的政治改组。第七阶段，指责半岛电视台。第八阶段，组织付费示威支持你的政权。第九阶段，发表关于你多么热爱青年的屈尊纡贵的演讲。第十阶段，威胁说没有你国家将陷入混乱。第十一阶段，指责外国煽动者。其实还有第十二阶段，但那是独裁者永远不想到达的阶段，因为那是离开。滚出去。
I called a guy named Marc Lynch to make sure I wasn't hallucinating these 11 stages repeating in one dictatorship after another. Marc runs the Middle East Studies program at George Washington University. He blogs at foreignpolicy.com. When I started reading him my list, he got excited and put the phone down for a second.
我打电话给一个叫马克·林奇（Marc Lynch）的人，以确保我不是在幻觉中看到这些11个阶段在每个独裁政权中重复出现。马克在乔治华盛顿大学负责中东研究项目。他在foreignpolicy.com上写博客。当我开始读我的清单给他听时，他很兴奋，把电话放下了一秒钟。
Hold on, hold on, hold on. Are you ready?
等一下，等一下，等一下。你准备好了吗？
Yes.
是的。
He went over to his computer, because he's actually been seeing a bunch of these lists in the Arabic language media, plus tons of comments about the weirdly similar script these dictators seem to be following. Every day, people are weighing in from Syria, Egypt, Bahrain, Libya, Yemen.
他走到电脑前，因为他实际上已经在阿拉伯语媒体中看到了一堆这样的清单，加上大量关于这些独裁者似乎在遵循奇怪相似剧本的评论。每天，都有来自叙利亚、埃及、巴林、利比亚、也门的人在发表意见。
It's been all over Twitter and Facebook. Activists from the Middle East, they've all noticed it. And so you'll see people from Yemen saying, Ali Abdullah Saleh is now on stage three, he's begun to meet the protesters' demands, but he's refusing to resign.
这在Twitter和Facebook上到处都是。中东的活动家，他们都注意到了。所以你会看到也门人说，阿里·阿卜杜拉·萨利赫（Ali Abdullah Saleh）现在处于第三阶段，他已经开始满足抗议者的要求，但他拒绝辞职。
When the unrest was beginning to get especially heavy in Syria, there were a lot of people asking, why hasn't Bashar al-Assad said anything? Why hasn't he given a speech? And the joke that was making the rounds was, "Well, he doesn't want to give speech number one, because he knows that after the third speech, he's gone."
当叙利亚的动荡开始变得特别严重时，有很多人问，为什么巴沙尔·阿萨德（Bashar al-Assad）什么都没说？为什么他不发表演讲？当时流传的笑话是：“好吧，他不想发表第一次演讲，因为他知道第三次演讲之后，他就完了。”
And that joke raises the central question here. With two dictators, Egypt's and Tunisia's, already thrown out by their people, why would any other dictators keep plodding through the same 11 stages the previous ones did?
那个笑话提出了这里的核心问题。随着埃及和突尼斯两个独裁者已经被人民赶下台，为什么其他独裁者还会继续走前任们走过的相同的11个阶段呢？
I think that Arab leaders have grown accustomed over decades to not having to respond to their people. And they're not used to having to really take seriously what their people say, and I think that decades of that really breeds this tin ear. When they're finally forced to listen, they're unable to hear.
我认为阿拉伯领导人几十年来已经习惯了不必回应他们的人民。他们不习惯于真的去认真对待人民说的话，我认为几十年来这种习惯真的滋生了这种听不进意见的毛病。当他们最终被迫倾听时，他们已经无法听到了。
The fact that they're unable to hear and take seriously their protesters' demands is clearest in the speeches these dictators have been giving. Each one is full of these bizarre echoes of the others.
他们无法倾听并认真对待抗议者要求的事实，在这些独裁者发表的演讲中表现得最为明显。每一场演讲都充满了彼此之间怪异的回声。
The empty promises of reform that nobody believes. The promises to step down sometime in the future. The claim that we are with the people, we hear what you're saying. All of these have become so frequent and so repetitive, that as soon as people hear them, it's like, "Oh, there he goes again. He's saying the same things that Ben Ali said, the same things that Mubarak said."
没人相信的改革空头支票。承诺在未来某个时候下台。宣称“我们与人民同在，我们听到了你们在说什么”。所有这些都变得如此频繁和重复，以至于人们一听到就觉得：“哦，他又来了。他说的话和本·阿里（Ben Ali）说的一样，和穆巴拉克（Mubarak）说的一样。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演讲]
So here is former Egyptian president Hosni Mubarak making the speech that, in retrospect, seems to have become the template for other dictators, although no one's been able to reproduce Mubarak's exact blend of condescension and menace. Here he is doing step five from the list, promising to investigate who shot people.
所以这是前埃及总统穆巴拉克发表的演讲，回想起来，这似乎已经成为了其他独裁者的模板，尽管没人能复制穆巴拉克那种屈尊与威胁的混合体。他在这里进行列表中的第五步，承诺调查是谁枪杀了民众。
I tell you that all those who're injured, their blood will not go down the drain. And I confirm that I will penalize all those responsible, and I will hold accountable those who committed crimes against the rights of our youth.
我告诉你们，所有受伤的人，他们的鲜血不会白流。我确认我将惩罚所有负责任的人，我将追究那些对我们青年权利犯罪的人的责任。
The youth. That's stage nine, talking about his love for the youth.
青年。那是第九阶段，谈论他对青年的热爱。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语演讲]
The citizens, the children of Egypt, men and women, I address you today. To the youth of Egypt, I address you all with a speech from the heart, a speech from father to his children, to his sons and daughters. I tell you, I take pride in you, dreaming of a bright future and shaping such a future.
公民们，埃及的孩子们，男人们女人们，我今天向你们讲话。埃及的青年，我用发自肺腑的演讲向你们所有人讲话，一场从父亲对孩子，对儿子和女儿的演讲。我告诉你们，我为你们感到骄傲，梦想着光明的未来并塑造这样的未来。
Utter nonsense delivered with utter conviction. By the time Mubarak spoke these words, more than 300 people had been killed during the protests in Egypt. Of course, nothing Mubarak said saved him from progressing to stage 12 and leaving. But other dictators learned by watching what happened to him, and they've managed to hold on by just repeating and escalating steps two through eight-- the thugs, the political reshuffles, the paid counter-demonstrations, the shootings and killings.
完全的胡言乱语，却带着完全的自信发表出来。当穆巴拉克说出这些话时，埃及的抗议活动中已经有超过300人丧生。当然，穆巴拉克所说的一切都没能让他免于进入第12阶段并离开。但其他独裁者通过观察发生在他身上的事情学到了经验，他们设法通过仅仅重复和升级第二到第八阶段——暴徒、政治改组、付费的反示威、枪击和杀戮——来维持权力。
The big difference in a lot of the cases-- between Tunisia and Egypt on the one hand and what we're seeing now-- is that, for the most part, both in Tunisia and Egypt, the army refrained from carrying out massive violence against protesters. And one of the lessons that the Arab dictators learned is that that doesn't save them.
在许多情况下，突尼斯和埃及与我们现在看到的情况之间的巨大区别在于，大多数情况下，突尼斯和埃及的军队都克制住了不对抗议者进行大规模暴力。阿拉伯独裁者学到的教训之一是，这样做并不能拯救他们。
And so from Bahrain to Syria, to Yemen, to Libya, what we see in the next round is the willingness to unleash deadly force to stay in power. And it's one of the reasons why the excitement of the Arab world back in January and February has given way to the grimmer realities that we have right now.
所以从巴林到叙利亚，到也门，到利比亚，我们在下一轮中看到的是使用致命武力来保持权力的意愿。这也是为什么阿拉伯世界一月和二月的兴奋感让位于我们现在所拥有的严峻现实的原因之一。
It is grim. There are dead and jailed protesters in six countries now. And most of these dictators aren't going anywhere.
这很严峻。现在有六个国家的抗议者死亡和入狱。而且这些独裁者中的大多数哪儿也不会去。
Nancy Updike's one of the producers of our show. Coming up, they tried to make me go to rehab, and I said, no, no, no, I will go to Minnesota. That is in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作者之一。接下来，他们想让我去戒毒所，我说，不，不，不，我要去明尼苏达。那将在几分钟后播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bringing you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Know When To Fold 'Em, stories of people who wait way too long before folding their cards, dropping out, stepping aside, stepping down. Sometimes, to be fair, out of sheer confusion as to what's best. We've arrived at act three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“何时该弃牌”，讲述了人们在弃牌、退出、靠边站、下台前等待时间太久的故事。有时，公平地说，是出于对什么是最好的完全困惑。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Gin Rummy. One of the principles of treating alcoholism is that there's hope for everyone. Everyone still has the possibility of quitting, you're not supposed to give up on anybody, you never fold your cards. But in Saint Paul, and a few other places too, they have something that clinically they call housing for chronic late stage alcoholics, but most people just call a wet house.
第三幕，金拉米纸牌游戏（Gin Rummy）。治疗酒精中毒的原则之一是每个人都有希望。每个人都还有退出的可能性，你不应该放弃任何人，你永远不会弃牌。但在圣保罗，以及其他一些地方，有一种临床上被称为“慢性晚期酒精中毒者住房”的地方，但大多数人直接称之为“湿屋”（wet house）。
The idea is, alcoholics live there-- you have to be an alcoholic to get in, people are referred from detox centers-- and they let them continue to drink. Which is the opposite of most shelters. Most shelters, if you're caught drinking you are out, at least until you sober up. Same goes for rehab centers, and treatment programs-- if you're drunk, you're gone.
这个概念是，酒精中毒者住在那儿——你必须是酒精中毒者才能入住，人们从戒毒中心转介而来——他们让他们继续喝酒。这与大多数收容所相反。大多数收容所，如果你被发现喝酒你就出局了，至少在你清醒之前。康复中心和治疗项目也是如此——如果你醉了，你就被踢走了。
This idea of a place where drunks can stay drunk and get housing makes a lot of people angry. The one in Saint Paul, called St. Anthony Residence, is run by Catholic charities, but with some state money in there, too. Reporter Marc Sanchez visited St. Anthony House to see how it works.
这种让醉汉可以保持醉酒状态并获得住房的地方让很多人感到愤怒。圣保罗的那家名为“圣安东尼住所”（St. Anthony Residence）的地方，由天主教慈善机构运营，但其中也有一些州政府的资金。记者马克·桑切斯（Marc Sanchez）参观了圣安东尼住所，看看它是如何运作的。
There're no guys passed out in front of St. Anthony Residence when I pull up. No broken bottles on the sidewalk, either. The building itself looks like it should have a sign on the outside advertising loft apartments. Inside, it's surprisingly nice free housing. 60 rooms, quite and orderly. Every guy who lives here-- they're all men, by the way-- each guy gets his own room with a lock on the door.
当我驱车抵达时，圣安东尼住所门口没有倒下的家伙。人行道上也没有破碎的瓶子。建筑本身看起来应该在外面挂个牌子做阁楼公寓广告。里面，这是出奇好的免费住房。60个房间，安静且有序。住在这里的每个家伙——顺便说一句，他们都是男性——每个人都有带锁的独立房间。
Breakfast, lunch, and dinner are served up by the kitchen staff. Or if you miss a meal, you can grab a sandwich anytime you want. Each resident collects $89 a month in general assistance from the state, and after buying essentials like razors and toothpaste, several of the guys told me that at least half their money goes towards booze.
厨房工作人员提供早餐、午餐和晚餐。或者如果你错过了饭点，你可以随时拿个三明治。每个居民每月从州政府领取89美元的公共援助，在购买了剃须刀和牙膏等必需品后，几个家伙告诉我，他们至少一半的钱都花在了买酒上。
Well, I have to tell you, about 85% of my time I spend drinking.
好吧，我得告诉你，我大约85%的时间都花在喝酒上。
That's Nick. And for privacy's sake, I'm only going to use his and other residents' first names.
那是尼克。为了隐私起见，我只会使用他和住户们的名字。
On days that you are drinking, when do you typically start drinking?
在你喝酒的日子里，你通常什么时候开始喝酒？
Whenever. You know, when the liquor stores open usually is a good time for me. And if I have booze on me, it's always nice to have a drink when you wake up, and you're-- at 3 o'clock in the morning. It doesn't matter what time of day it is.
随便吧。你知道，通常酒类商店开门的时候是我喝酒的好时间。如果我有酒在身边，醒来时喝上一杯总是很不错，哪怕是在凌晨3点。不管是什么时候都无所谓。
You're not allowed to have booze in your room, so if it's 3:00 in the morning, he has to go to a little patio out back, the one place here where you can drink. If guys have any alcohol on them when they come home, they check it in at the front desk, where someone's on duty 24 hours. The staff member will take out a big black marker and tag the bottle with its owner's last name. The alcohol is simply placed on a table in a room behind the front desk. There's no lock and key.
你不允许在房间里有酒，所以如果是凌晨3点，他必须去后面一个小露台，那是这里唯一可以喝酒的地方。如果住户回家时身上有酒，他们会在前台登记，那里24小时有人值班。工作人员会拿出一支大黑记号笔，在瓶子上标注主人的姓氏。酒精就简单地放在前台后面房间的一张桌子上。没有锁和钥匙。
And you can see, there is very little here-- one, two, three, four, five. Six bottles and two 12 packs. And they'll put your name on it, and when you come back you check it out, and you go out to the patio and have your drink.
你可以看到，这里剩下的很少——一、二、三、四、五。六瓶酒和两箱12罐装的酒。他们会写上你的名字，当你回来时你签出它，然后去露台上喝酒。
The guy showing me around is Bill Hockenberger. He's the program manager at St. Anthony. Bill's a recovering alcoholic, and he used to run with some of these guys in his drinking days. He's been sober for almost 16 years now, but he says he could have easily ended up living here.
带我参观的人是比尔·霍肯伯格（Bill Hockenberger）。他是圣安东尼的项目经理。比尔是一名正在康复的酒精中毒者，他在喝酒的时候也曾和这些家伙混在一起。他现在已经清醒了近16年了，但他表示他本来也很容易以住在这里告终。
We go to his office, and before I even have a chance to sit down, he goes to a metal filing cabinet and pulls out a yellow candy box with a picture of a cartoon cactus on it. It's filled with photos.
我们走进他的办公室，我还没来得及坐下，他就走向一个金属档案柜，拿出一个黄色的糖果盒，上面画着一个卡通仙人掌。里面装满了照片。
These here are just my daily reminders of some of my drinking days here. You can see where the-- a couple of the fights that I've been in, the results of some of that. You can see my jaw swollen out of shape there, my eyes totally black, and the whites of my eyes are covered with blood, bruised down the side there.
这些是我在这里喝酒日子里的一些日常提醒。你可以看到——我打过几次架，这些就是结果。你可以看到我下巴变形肿胀的样子，我的眼睛完全是黑的，眼白布满了血，那一侧有淤青。
Was that common for the time? Getting in fights like that?
那时候这常见吗？像那样去打架？
Not to be on the receiving end of it like that, no. No, that was why I think I took pictures of this, because this was pretty much one of the battles that I was never too happy with.
不，作为被打的一方不是，不。不，那就是为什么我想我拍下这些照片的原因，因为这基本是我从不感到高兴的战斗之一。
I noticed you keep the pictures in this candy box, is there a significance to that?
我注意到你把照片放在这个糖果盒里，这有什么意义吗？
No, I just keep them close by me. This is for some time when I want to remind myself, or let a resident know that I've also been down the road with them.
不，我只是把它们放在我身边。这是为了提醒我自己，或者让住户知道我也曾和他们一起走过那段路。
Bill's story rivals anyone's at St. Anthony. It wasn't until his body completely shut down-- his liver was failing, he fell into a coma for nine days-- that he quit for good.
比尔的故事不亚于圣安东尼的任何人。直到他的身体完全崩溃——肝脏衰竭，他昏迷了九天——他才彻底戒酒。
And you can see how totally yellow-- I look like a banana.
你可以看到我是多么完全地变黄了——我看起来像根香蕉。
Bill's quick to point out that St. Anthony's services aren't treatment. But there's an on-site nurse who administers preventative care twice a week. Residents also meet with counselors who set goals like getting a state ID or making a trip to the dentist. And if staff notices a pattern in someone coming in and falling over drunk, they'll step in.
比尔很快指出，圣安东尼的服务不是治疗。但有一名现场护士每周两次提供预防性护理。住户还会与辅导员会面，设定目标，例如获取州身份证或去牙医那里看牙。如果工作人员注意到某人有醉倒进来的模式，他们会介入。
We're not going to let a resident come in here and drink to excess here. We're here to monitor their drinking a bit and make sure that they don't endanger themselves by drinking rubbing alcohol. They're not drinking mouthwash. We try to get them to taper off onto some beer if they're drinking vodka and they have a hard time walking or being mobile.
我们不会让住户来这里过度饮酒。我们在这里是为了稍微监控他们的饮酒，确保他们不会通过喝外用酒精来危及自己。他们不会喝漱口水。如果他们喝的是伏特加，走路或行动困难，我们尽量让他们改喝啤酒。
We'll talk to them a little bit, and their goal is, "Listen, next time you go to the liquor store, instead of buying a half a gallon, why don't you try buying a pint? Try to drink in moderation a little bit here."
我们会和他们谈谈，他们的目标是：“听着，下次你去酒行时，与其买半加仑，为什么不试着买一品脱呢？试着稍微适度地喝一点。”
It seems like total hopelessness and just giving up on people. Like, you're not really worth fighting for. You're not really worth recovery anyway. So, bottoms up.
这看起来像是彻底的绝望，只是放弃了人们。就像，你真的不值得争取。无论如何，你真的不值得康复。所以，干杯吧。
Nell Hurley is another person who went from drinking to trying to help drinkers. She runs the Minnesota Recovery Connection. They're basically the yellow pages for recovery in the state. When word got out about St. Anthony in the recovery community, people were upset. She says it's hard for her to justify not stepping in.
内尔·赫尔利（Nell Hurley）是另一位从喝酒转向试图帮助饮酒者的人。她经营着明尼苏达康复联络处。他们基本上是该州康复服务的黄页。当圣安东尼的消息在康复界传开时，人们感到不安。她说，她很难证明不介入是合理的。
I mean, I'm all about keeping people safe and giving someone a blanket. I don't at all want to come off like, "If they're going to drink, let them be cold," or whatever. But there should be more of an attempt to rehabilitate or guide someone into recovery.
我的意思是，我完全支持保障人们的安全并给某人一条毯子。我一点也不想表现得好像，“如果他们要喝酒，就让他们冷着吧，”或者类似的话。但应该有更多的尝试来帮助某人康复或引导某人进入康复状态。
The minute somebody wants to go to a program, we have referral places for them.
一旦有人想去参加项目，我们有转介中心给他们。
Again, Bill Hockenberger.
再次说明，比尔·霍肯伯格。
We have an AA right down the corner here, and I will drive you there personally and see that you make it to AA meetings. And we do have people that do recover out of here, that do take in their own programs, and we support them 100%. You know, I can't help but not say this. The residents here, the clients here, have been through treatment so many times that they know the program better than the counselors do. I mean, they have the tools and what it takes to stay sober, but they just can't-- they can't do it.
我们在这街角就有AA（匿名戒酒互助社），我会亲自开车送你去那里，确保你去参加AA会议。我们确实有人在这里康复了，确实参加了他们自己的项目，我们100%支持他们。你知道，我忍不住要说这个。这里的住户，这里的客户，经历过治疗太多次了，他们比咨询师更了解这个项目。我的意思是，他们有保持清醒的工具和条件，但他们就是不能——他们做不到。
I don't want to ever give up hope. I don't want to ever give up hope on anybody.
我不想永远放弃希望。我不想永远放弃任何人。
I think people think that by letting them drink, you are giving up hope.
我认为人们认为通过让他们喝酒，你就在放弃希望。
Well, I'm not certainly one of them. If they have a better plan, than I'd certainly like to hear it.
好吧，我当然不是其中之一。如果他们有更好的计划，我当然很想听听。
The biggest argument for a wet house like St. Anthony is one I heard from a resident named Paul. And it comes down to this: before he came here, Paul used to sleep under a bridge, even in the winter.
像圣安东尼这样的“湿屋”最大的理由是我从一个名叫保罗的住户那里听到的。归根结底是：在他来到这里之前，保罗甚至在冬天也睡在桥下。
Depending on who you know down there, it can be rough. If you know people down there who can help watch your back.
取决于你在下面认识谁，那可能会很艰难。如果你认识在下面能帮你照看后背的人。
I just don't understand, like a week like last week, where it was 30 below. Like I don't--
我只是不明白，就像上周那样，温度降到零下30度。就像我不——
When it got that cold, I'd go over to Dorothy Day.
当天气冷的时候，我会去多萝西·戴（Dorothy Day）。
That's another shelter?
那是另一个收容所？
Yeah. I don't like Dorothy Day.
是的。我不喜欢多萝西·戴。
Why don't you like Dorothy Day?
你为什么不喜欢多萝西·戴？
Because if you sleep too hard, you could end up having your backpack stolen. Because you've got people right next to you, just like as close as me and you. And some people down there ain't the cleanest. But if we didn't have this place, we'd be in the streets, you know, causing problems. The police would have to deal with us, the emergency rooms, courts. It helps a whole lot.
因为如果你睡得太死，你的背包可能会被偷。因为你旁边的人离你很近，就像我和你一样近。下面有些人并不是最干净的。但如果我们没有这个地方，我们就会在街上，你知道，制造麻烦。警察必须处理我们，急诊室，法院。这有很大帮助。
Do you ever think that there's going to be a day that you'll leave here?
你有没有想过有一天你会离开这里？
I don't know. I don't know. There ain't no other place to go.
我不知道。我不知道。没有其他地方可以去。
As for how many guys make it into treatment from St. Anthony, they tally that up once a year. In their 2010 report, out of the 87 guys who were served, only 10 went into treatment. After all, that isn't their goal here.
至于有多少人从圣安东尼进入治疗，他们一年统计一次。在他们的2010年报告中，在服务的87人中，只有10人进入了治疗。毕竟，那不是他们的目标。
And when I visited, I had this feeling-- it's nice and clean and everyone's respectful of each other, but it's really sad. Walking down the hallway I could hear muffled TVs playing in their rooms, and I got the sense that people are slowly killing themselves behind their closed doors. During that year when 10 guys went into treatment, three other residents died. When that happens, Deacon James Meyer comes in for services. Everyone calls him Deacon Jim.
当我参观时，我有一种感觉——这里整洁干净，每个人都互相尊重，但这真的很悲伤。走在走廊里，我能听到房间里电视发出沉闷的声音，我感觉人们在关闭的门后慢慢地杀害自己。在那一年，有10个人进入治疗，其他三个住户去世了。发生这种情况时，执事詹姆斯·迈耶（Deacon James Meyer）会进来主持仪式。每个人都叫他吉姆执事。
For some, this is the end of the road for them. And they may die here. They're never going to make that choice and that connection, say, "I'm ready to get out of here." I like drinking more than I dislike being here or giving up the things I've given up in my life."
对一些人来说，这是他们的尽头。他们可能会死在这里。他们永远不会做出那个选择和那种联系，说：“我准备好离开这里了。我喜欢喝酒胜过讨厌待在这里，或者放弃我生命中已经放弃的东西。”
Is that hard for you, though, to--
虽然这对你来说很难吗——
Yeah, it is hard. It is hard. But we care for them where they are. If they're ready to move, if they're not ready to move, that's really not our call here. Our call is to love them.
是的，确实很难。确实很难。但我们在他们所在的地方照顾他们。如果他们准备好移动，如果他们没准备好移动，那真的不是我们的决定。我们的使命是爱他们。
Maybe this is obvious, but trying to care for alcoholics is messy. When I was in his office, Bill showed me a letter from a resident who had checked into St. Anthony in October of 1992, almost 20 years ago. Last summer, Bill coaxed him into trying a treatment facility up north, but in the letter, the guy told Bill that he was done, and he wanted to move back to St. Anthony in the spring.
也许这很明显，但试图照顾酒精中毒者是很混乱的。当我在他的办公室时，比尔给我看了一封来自住户的信，他在1992年10月，也就是近20年前入住圣安东尼。去年夏天，比尔劝说他尝试去北边的一家治疗机构，但在信中，那家伙告诉比尔他受够了，他想在春天搬回圣安东尼。
Bill wrote back and told the guy he was proud of him for getting as far as he had, and that he should try to stay where he is. He should stick with the program. But sure, he said, he'd take him back. A month later, the guy moved back into St. Anthony. He's there now, drinking again.
比尔回信告诉他，为他能走到这一步感到自豪，他应该试着留在原处。他应该坚持那个项目。但当然，他说，他会让他回来的。一个月后，那家伙搬回了圣安东尼。他现在就在那里，又开始喝酒了。
Marc Sanchez is a producer from Minnesota Public Radio, he normally works on a feature called Minnesota Sounds.
马克·桑切斯是明尼苏达公共广播电台的制作者，他通常负责一个叫“明尼苏达之声”（Minnesota Sounds）的专栏。
[MUSIC - "SORRY YOU'RE SICK" BY TED HAWKINS]
[音乐 - 泰德·霍金斯（Ted Hawkins）的《抱歉你病了》（SORRY YOU'RE SICK）]
Act Four, Solitaire and Everything's Wild. Now this story of tenacity and not giving up, and then, suddenly, I would say kind of heroically, giving up completely, and laying down the cards in an unprecedented, kind of amazing way.
第四幕，纸牌接龙与万能牌。现在这个关于坚持不懈和不放弃的故事，然后，突然，我会说相当英雄般地，完全放弃，并以一种前所未有的、令人惊叹的方式放下底牌。
This story happens in Brazil, in a part of Brazil that was all rain forest, almost nobody lived there until the 1970s. Then development came very quickly, a million people in just a couple decades moved there, cutting down rain forest, replacing it with logging operations and ranching, building towns and cities. Monte Reel was the South American correspondent for the Washington Post when he first heard about what happened. It all started as a rumor going around logging camps back in the mid-1990s.
这个故事发生在巴西，在巴西的一个全部是雨林的地区，直到1970年代几乎没有人住在那里。然后开发很快到来，短短几十年内有百万人搬到那里，砍伐雨林，取而代之的是伐木业和畜牧业，建设城镇和城市。蒙特·里尔（Monte Reel）在第一次听到发生的事情时是《华盛顿邮报》的南美记者。这一切都始于1990年代中期在伐木营地流传的一个传言。
And the scouts begin telling the story of a, quote unquote, "wild man" who lived out in the forest. And he didn't appear to have any tie to anyone else at all. He appeared to be completely alone. And the story of this started to go around these logging camps and into some towns, and it finally caught the ear of a guy named Marcelo dos Santos who worked for the Brazilian government for FUNAI, which is the equivalent of the Bureau of Indigenous Affairs.
侦察兵开始讲述一个在森林里生活的所谓的“野人”的故事。他似乎与任何人都没有任何联系。他看起来完全是一个人。这个故事开始在伐木营地和一些城镇中流传，最终传到了一个叫马塞洛·多斯桑托斯（Marcelo dos Santos）的人的耳朵里，他为巴西政府的FUNAI工作，这相当于印第安事务局。
And his job was to try to find any isolated tribes that remained in that area and protect them from development. So he heard this rumor and he started to investigate. And they would go out on periodic expeditions to try to find this guy.
他的工作是试图找到该地区残存的任何孤立部落，并保护他们免受开发。所以他听到了这个传言，并开始调查。他们会定期进行探险，试图找到这个家伙。
The first thing that they found was a hut. The company cook at the logging camp took them to this hut that he had seen. And the hut was very small. It was made out of palm wood and thatch, and it was only big enough for one person to live in. And in the middle of this hut, the strange, kind of identifying feature, was a hole that was about five and a half feet deep. It was a rectangular hole.
他们发现的第一件事是一个小屋。伐木营地的厨师带他们去了这个他见过的小屋。小屋非常小。它是用棕榈木和茅草盖的，只有一个人住的大小。在这个小屋的中间，那个奇怪的、某种标识性的特征，是一个深约五英尺半的洞。那是一个长方形的洞。
In this tiny, tiny space?
在这么小的空间里？
Yeah. And none of these guys had ever seen anything like this among the other tribes. They really didn't know what it was or what purpose it served. And so they continued looking, and they spent, actually, a couple of months going out into this area of the forest. And they started to find other huts. He had basically built them quickly and abandoned them as the loggers got closer. So he was kind of on the run.
是的。而且这些家伙在其他部落中从来没见过这样的东西。他们真的不知道它是什么，也不知道它有什么目的。所以他们继续寻找，实际上，他们花了几个月的时间进入森林的这个区域。他们开始发现其他小屋。随着伐木工越来越近，他基本上是迅速建造了这些小屋然后遗弃它们。所以他有点在逃亡。
So this team led by Marcelo dos Santos would head out on these missions to find this guy. And they were scared that if ranchers or developers get to him first, they'll do to him what they usually do-- kill him. The team wants to reach the guy and then figure out a safe place where other tribes live that maybe they could relocate him to.
所以这个由马塞洛·多斯桑托斯领导的团队会出发去执行任务找到这个家伙。他们害怕如果牧场主或开发商先找到他，他们会对他做他们通常做的事——杀了他。团队想要接触到他，然后找一个安全的地方，那里住着其他部落，也许他们可以让他搬迁到那里。
So they're heading out into the rain forest, but making first contact with any isolated tribe is incredibly dangerous. Often there's violence. Monte Reel says that 120 in this government agency FUNAI have been killed over the years.
所以他们正前往雨林，但与任何孤立部落进行第一次接触都极其危险。通常会有暴力。蒙特·里尔说，这个政府机构FUNAI的120人在过去几年中被杀害。
The team assumes that the guy that they're looking for, who they call the Indio-- the Indian-- doesn't speak any language that they know. So as they walk through the jungle, they make these whistling sounds so that he doesn't think that they're trying to sneak up on him. The leave gifts for the guy-- seeds, machete, stuff he might find useful-- hoping that he understands that they're leaving this as gifts specifically for him.
团队认为他们正在寻找的那个被称为“Indio”（印第安人）的家伙，不说他们认识的任何语言。所以当他们在丛林中穿行时，他们会发出这些吹口哨的声音，这样他就不会认为他们是在试图偷袭他。他们给那个家伙留下礼物——种子、弯刀，他可能觉得有用的东西——希望他理解他们是专门为他留下的礼物。
It's really, really tricky. And there's no real guidebook for how to how to act in that situation.
这真的，真的很棘手。而且对于在那种情况下该怎么做，没有任何真正的指南。
What's their plan on how they're going to communicate with him? Do you know what I mean? Did you talk to them about that?
他们打算如何与他沟通？你知道我的意思吗？你有和他们谈过那个吗？
Yeah. In this particular case, they actually brought along Pura Kanoe. He was a member of the Kanoe tribe that they had discovered just months before. So they brought him on those early expeditions hoping that he might be able to communicate with the Indian if they had an encounter. Or at the very least that he might make the encounter more friendly or more natural.
有的。在这个特定的案例中，他们实际上带来了普拉·卡诺埃（Pura Kanoe）。他是他们几个月前刚刚发现的卡诺埃部落的一名成员。所以他们把他带上了那些早期的探险任务，希望如果他们遇到那个印第安人，他可能能够与他沟通。或者至少他可能会让接触变得更友好或更自然。
Then, in late 1996, they got their first break. Satellite photos showed a clearing in the rain forest where there was no reason for a clearing to exist. When they go there, they find the remains of a village, over a dozen huts.
然后，在1996年末，他们第一次有了突破。卫星照片显示雨林中有一块空地，没有理由存在那样的空地。当他们去那里时，他们发现了村庄的遗迹，有十几间小屋。
But they were built in the same style as this particular Indian's. And they each had those holes, the same kind of holes inside the huts. So after investigating that, they believed that this was the site of the village that he had come from.
但它们是按照这个特定印第安人的风格建造的。而且每一间小屋里都有那些洞，同样种类的洞。所以在调查之后，他们认为这就是他所属村庄的遗址。
The team assumed that everybody in the village had been slaughtered, which can make the guy even more wary of outsiders, less interested in being found.
团队认为村庄里的每个人都被屠杀了，这可能会让那个家伙对外界更加警惕，对被发现更不感兴趣。
So talk about what happens when they finally see him in person for the first time.
那么谈谈当他们第一次亲眼见到他时发生了什么。
The first time that they saw him, it was a group of, I believe, three people. And they were walking through the forest, and they saw him kneeling down, sort of in a contemplative pose. They approached with their palms up. They walked very, very slowly, so as not to appear threatening at all.
他们第一次见到他时，那是一群人，我相信有三个人。他们正在森林里走，看到他跪着，姿势像是沉思的样子。他们手掌向上走近。他们走得非常非常慢，以免看起来有威胁。
What does he look like? What can they see?
他长什么样？他们能看到什么？
He appears to be in his mid to late 30s. He's not wearing any clothes except for a breechcloth around his waist, dried grasses that hang down. He has an arm band, a vegetable fiber arm band. He doesn't wear body paint, and he has black hair, and he had a little bit of a mustache-- a very thin mustache that looked almost like a goatee.
他看起来大概在30多岁到快40岁。他没穿任何衣服，除了腰间有一块腰布，干草垂下来。他有一个臂带，植物纤维臂带。他不涂人体彩绘，黑头发，有一点点胡子——很细的胡子，看起来几乎像山羊胡。
But as they tried to get a little closer, he heard them, and he ran back into his hut. And it was sort of a stand off. And they didn't push it at that time, they didn't try to force contact. They figured, "Well, we'll have other opportunities for this." And they left. He went on the run.
但当他们试图靠近一点时，他听到了他们的声音，跑回了他的小屋。那有点像是僵持。他们当时没有强行接触，没有尝试强行接触。他们心想，“好吧，我们还有其他机会。”他们离开了。他继续逃亡。
So you figure, a guy on foot who's technologically still somewhere in the Bronze Age, maybe, versus modern people with satellite tracking, and vehicles, and expertise-- how long could he evade them? Two years. It takes two full years before they spot him again. And they are tenacious. They do not give up, because they feel like time is running out. They've got to establish a relationship with this guy so he trusts them, before anybody else finds him and kills him.
所以你算算，一个靠双脚行走，技术水平可能还在青铜时代的人，对抗拥有卫星追踪、车辆和专业知识的现代人——他能避开他们多久？两年。足足用了两年时间他们才再次发现他。而且他们很顽强。他们不放弃，因为他们觉得时间不多了。他们必须与这个家伙建立关系让他信任他们，在别人找到他并杀了他之前。
Sometimes they find huts, sometimes they find signs of him. Finally, they see the guy himself.
有时他们发现小屋，有时他们发现他的踪迹。最后，他们看到了他本人。
And they had an encounter that just was a standoff for hours and hours. And the Indian was inside the hut, and he had an arrow, and the arrowhead was pointing out of the hut. It's a thatch-sided hut, so the arrow could actually protrude out of the wall.
他们发生了一次持续了数小时的僵持。那个印第安人在小屋里，他有一支箭，箭头指向小屋外面。那是茅草墙的小屋，所以箭实际上可以从墙壁中伸出来。
And every now and then, he would lower the arrow, but as soon as they tried to approach closer, he would raise the arrow again. So it was kind of this dance back and forth. They would try to get close, he would raise the arrow, they would back off. They tried to give him gifts of corn and seeds. They actually put some corn on the end of a long stick and pushed it up there, so that he could take the corn. He took the corn inside the hut and almost immediately threw it back out again.
每隔一段时间，他会把箭放低，但只要他们试图靠近，他就会再次举起箭。所以这有点像来回的舞蹈。他们会试图靠近，他就会举起箭，他们会退后。他们试图给他玉米和种子的礼物。他们实际上把一些玉米放在长棍的末端推上去，让他可以拿玉米。他把玉米拿进小屋，几乎立刻又把它扔了出来。
They would sort of crawl up towards the hut saying, "Friend, please, we're friendly." And eventually, he shot an arrow at the guy with the camera, at Vincent-- just narrowly missed his torso. And after that they decided to give up that particular attempt at contact.
他们会向着小屋爬去，说：“朋友，请，我们是友好的。”最终，他向那个拿着摄像机的人，也就是文森特，射了一支箭——险些击中他的躯干。在那之后他们决定放弃那次特定的接触尝试。
It's such a strange encounter because he's giving them such clear signals. He wants them to go away the entire time.
这种遭遇太奇怪了，因为他一直在给他们明确的信号。他一直希望他们走开。
Yeah. Yeah, it's funny because it was shortly after that that all of the members of the team came to this decision to change strategy completely. They basically decided instead of pursuing him-- because he was on the run from them now, as well as from the developers.
是的。是的，很有趣，因为在那之后不久，团队的所有成员都做出了完全改变策略的决定。他们基本决定不再追逐他——因为他现在不仅是在躲避开发商，也在躲避他们。
There's a letter that one of the guys writes at this point. Can I ask you to just read that? It's on page 134 of your book.
有一个人当时写的一封信。我可以请你读一下吗？在你的书第134页。
"We feel embarrassed by our insistence in trying to contact him. The face of the Indian, always sullen, anxious, worried, and permanently silent, had made it clear to us that he wants to be left alone. Despite clearly demonstrating our conciliatory intentions, we continued to challenge his obvious decision. We finally concluded that we were assailing his rights. We resolved to suspend the attempts to contact him and shift our work in another direction."
“对于我们试图联系他的坚持，我们感到尴尬。印第安人始终阴沉、焦虑、担忧且长期沉默的面孔，已经明确向我们表明他希望被单独留下。尽管清晰地表明了我们和解的意图，我们仍继续挑战他明显的决定。我们最终得出结论，我们是在侵犯他的权利。我们决定暂停联系尝试，并将我们的工作转向另一个方向。”
So they not only fold their hand, they change the game. At the team's urging, the Brazilian government did this thing it had never done before. It set aside 31 square miles of forest for this one guy. In Rondonia, which was going through rapid development, this was incredibly controversial, and there was a political fight over it. FUNAI personnel assigned to the project became such lightning rods that one after another had to be replaced.
所以他们不仅弃牌了，他们改变了游戏规则。在团队的敦促下，巴西政府做了它以前从未做过的事情。它为这个家伙预留了31平方英里的森林。在正在经历快速开发的朗多尼亚州，这引起了极大的争议，并且为此发生了一场政治斗争。分配给该项目的FUNAI人员成了众矢之的，一个接一个不得不被替换。
There was a feeling in Rondonia that was kind of like a states' rights argument in our country. The national government of Brazil-- bureaucrats and politicians from the capital-- was making them set aside this huge swath of land for just one man, which seemed crazy to lots of people. But not only did the 31-square-mile refuge become the law, the law included the fact that if somebody went in and killed the lone tribesmen who lived there, the state still would not turn over the land to development, which removed the incentive to just go in and murder the guy.
朗多尼亚有一种感觉，有点像我们国家的“州权论”。巴西的中央政府——来自首都的官僚和政客——正在强迫他们为这一个人预留出如此大片的土地，这对很多人来说看起来很疯狂。但31平方英里的避难所不仅成了法律，法律还包括如果有人进入并杀害了住在那里的孤立部落成员，国家仍然不会将土地交给开发，这消除了仅仅进入并谋杀他的动机。
Government teams periodically would go in and check on him to be sure he was still there and still OK. But they did not try to interact with him, which worked. He started taking the gifts they left. He used the machete. He planted the corn seed. At one point, they actually got into a hut that he had not abandoned and they saw that that weird rectangular hole on the floor had a hammock slung over it. And they speculated that digging the hole so deep was probably some kind of spiritual ritual.
政府团队会定期进去查看他，确保他还在那里且没事。但他们没有尝试与他互动，这奏效了。他开始拿走他们留下的礼物。他使用了弯刀。他种下了玉米种子。有一次，他们实际上进入了一间他没有遗弃的小屋，看到地板上那个奇怪的长方形洞里挂着一个吊床。他们推测把洞挖得那么深可能是什么某种精神仪式。
One day, one of the team members, Paulo Pereira, was walking through the forest, didn't know the Indian was around.
有一天，团队成员之一保罗·佩雷拉（Paulo Pereira）正在森林里走，不知道那个印第安人在附近。
And he heard somebody yell out, "Ho." Just one word, very sharply, yelled out, "Ho." And Paulo stopped. He looked around, and he saw the Indian, and the Indian just casually left. He just walked behind a tree and disappeared into the forest.
他听到有人尖叫了一声，“Ho”。就一个词，非常尖锐地喊了一声，“Ho”。保罗停下来。他环顾四周，看到了那个印第安人，那个印第安人只是漫不经心地离开了。他只是走到了树后，消失在森林里。
Paulo looked down and realized that he was standing right near the lip of a hole that the Indian had dug and lined with sharp spikes to capture animals. The Indian was trying to warn him. The Indian didn't want him hurt.
保罗低头看去，意识到他正站在那个印第安人为了捕捉动物而挖掘并衬有尖刺的洞的边缘附近。那个印第安人是在试图警告他。印第安人不想让他受伤。
And that really made an impression on them. It was really the first interaction anybody had had with him.
这真的给他们留下了深刻的印象。这确实是任何人与他进行的第一次互动。
Is it fair to just leave him out there alone? Is it fair to him? It seems sort of sad.
让他一个人待在那里公平吗？对他公平吗？这看起来有点悲伤。
Yeah, I mean, that's one of the arguments that's made in favor of trying to force contact. That it's really hard to even just imagine-- to kind of wrap the head around-- what it's like to be that alone. He hasn't spoken to anyone for 15 years. It'll be 15 years in this upcoming year. And I can imagine spending a day without speaking with anyone. But when you think about a week of that, and then a month, and then a year, and then a decade, it's just really hard to wrap your head around what that experience is like.
是的，我是说，那是支持尝试强行接触的论点之一。甚至很难去想象——去理解——那种孤独是什么感觉。他已经15年没有和任何人说话了。今年将满15年。我可以想象一天不和任何人说话。但当你想到那一周，然后一个月，然后一年，然后十年，真的很难理解那种经历是什么感觉。
I just could not stop thinking about that. This kind of story-- there's a whole sub-genre of science fiction of last survivors. It tugs at something I think kind of primal, almost mythical. What is life like for someone who lives completely alone with no one else to fall back onto? And my mind originally went to one of two polar opposites. There's the Garden of Eden idea, that he's alone in the middle of the forest--
我简直无法停止思考那个。这种故事——有一个完整的“最后幸存者”科幻子类型。它触动了我想象中某种原始的、几乎神话般的东西。对于一个完全孤独，没有其他人可以依靠的人来说，生活是什么样的？我的思想最初走向了两个极端的其中之一。有“伊甸园”的想法，他孤独地待在森林中央——
Where there's ample food, and he goes and picks fruit, and he hunts animals.
那里有充足的食物，他去采摘水果，捕猎动物。
Yeah. It's not reality, but that's one way to look at it. Another way is that he's trapped in this post-apocalyptic horror story.
是的。那不是现实，但那是看待它的一种方式。另一种方式是他被困在这个后世界末日的恐怖故事里。
All this led Monte to look into the research on what extreme isolation does to people. He says there've been a few studies. And they show that it's not how isolated you are, it's how isolated you feel. It's a matter of perception. Different people in the same situation perceive it differently. He says isolation also tends to make people more spiritual, which then makes them feel less alone.
所有这一切导致蒙特深入研究关于极端孤立对人们影响的研究。他说已经有了一些研究。它们表明，并不是你有多孤立，而是你觉得有多孤立。这是一种感知的差异。处于同样情况下的不同人感知的不同。他说孤立也倾向于使人变得更精神化，这使他们感到不那么孤独。
Monte's heard of one other example of a man in Brazil who was the last survivor of his tribe. The man's name is [? Cada Pirru ?] and he spent almost 10 years wandering after the rest of his people were massacred. He was found in a town hundreds of miles from where his village had been and was put into a reserve with a different tribe.
蒙特听说过巴西的另一个男人的例子，他是他部落的最后一名幸存者。那个人的名字是[？Cada Pirru？]，在其余人被屠杀后，他花了近10年时间流浪。他在距离他村庄数百英里外的一个城镇被发现，并被安置在一个不同部落的保护区里。
When he first arrived, it was almost like a homecoming-- everybody celebrated. But soon, he built a hut off by himself in the forest alone. After all those years of solitude, he didn't want to be around other people.
当他刚到达时，那几乎就像是回家——每个人都在庆祝。但很快，他就在森林里独自盖了一间小屋。经历这些年的孤独之后，他不想和其他人在一起。
Monte Reel's book about the quest to find and save the one lone tribesman is called The Last of the Tribe.
蒙特·里尔关于寻找和拯救那名孤立部落成员的追求的书叫做《部落的最后一人》（The Last of the Tribe）。
[MUSIC - "THE GAMBLER" BY ELMER]
[音乐 - 埃尔默（Elmer）的《赌徒》（THE GAMBLER）]
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Ship. Production help from Eric Mennel. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman's filling in as our West Coast producer.
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔洪（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）和艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Ship）共同参与。埃里克·门内尔（Eric Mennel）提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。简·伯曼（Jen Berman）担任我们的西海岸制作者。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast or find old episodes you've never heard and listen to them for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org. We're on Twitter at thisamerlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获取我们的免费每周播客，或者找到你从未听过的旧集并完全免费收听，thisamericanlife.org。我们在Twitter上是thisamerlife。 《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who got so offended the other night as he was walking to his car in the radio station parking lot.
我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责我们的节目管理监督，那天晚上他在电台停车场走向他的车时感到非常冒犯。
And he heard somebody yell out, "Ho!" Just one word, very sharply, yelled out "Ho!"
他听到有人尖叫了一声，“Ho！”就一个词，非常尖锐地喊了一声“Ho！”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。